hi there so you may have seen this
already there's a cvpr paper called
pulse and what it does is it's a method
to up sample a pixelated image in a way
that makes it look realistic
but also that the again down sampled
variant matches the original down
sampled image so it's kind of a cycle
consistency loss together with a again
and all in all it's a method to
demonstrate how you could do this now
this has been trained on this face
dataset among others there it was a user
Bomb Z that made this into a collapse of
people could try it out and tweet it
this out and as you can see it works
pretty nicely it gives pretty nice
results on this particular data set but
of course people started playing around
with it and gave fairly funny results
like this or that that gets more into
the horrible category these so you can
see these ones I particularly liked from
being made into the little child so you
can see as soon as you get away from the
original kind of dataset modality you
are going to get these results that are
off and people started to notice that so
here you input Barack Obama and what
comes out is a fairly standard Caucasian
person someone tweeted out saying this
image speaks volumes about the dangers
of bias in AI I guess here is where the
entire story starts so young Luca weighs
in and says ml systems are biased when
data is biased this face up sampling
system makes everyone look white because
the network was pre trained on flick
face HQ which mainly contains white
people picks train the exact same system
on a date set from Senegal and everyone
will look African so this is pointing
out why this happens namely because the
data set is mainly Caucasian people so
the results of up sampling are going to
be mainly Caucasian people I mean this
is like a straightforward explanation of
why we're seeing what we're seeing
but of course this was not okay and here
is where the piling starts as an
interjection we have to talk about bias
in machine learning technically there is
a statistical notion of bias which has a
very rigorous definition and there is
the societal definition of bias and
these two things even though they're the
same word they're totally different a
machine learning system mainly consists
of four different parts there is a data
set the model the loss function and the
optimization procedure statistical bias
means whenever the model the loss or the
optimization procedure leads to a
situation where the outcome doesn't
reflect the distribution of the data
that you input this for example is
achieved when you regularize your model
which means that you put some prior
knowledge onto the model you introduce
bias and therefore you choose to not
accurately represent your data
distribution regularize it to a more
bias distribution that in turn has lower
variance we know this as the
bias-variance tradeoff it's actually
very simple right you you have the
Ferraris and the Lamborghinis and you
want make a model that predicts the
accident probability now it just so
happens that the Ferrari drivers are a
bit more reckless and they do slightly
higher accidents and now I train my
logistic regression and it tells me okay
6040 cool but now I train my logistic
regression with an l1 penalty and I say
I want my model to be you know
explainable so I wanted to be sparse I
want the least amount of variables to be
contributing to it what's the model
gonna say the models gonna say Ferrari
drivers add Lamborghini drivers good
societal bias and machine learning is
way different an example for this is
when face detection systems work well on
Caucasian people but don't work so well
faced with people from other Heritage's
and these societal biases are in the
dataset as young account points out here
if you change the dataset
you'll change these biases notably the
societal biases can only be in the data
set otherwise you'd have to argue
something like logistic regression
itself has a preference for white people
or something like this now there is a
considerable interaction effect between
the two but as Jung Lacan points out the
actual societal bias
of the final system is a direct result
of the bias in the dataset and he is
very correct if you train that system on
a different data set it will exhibit
different biases societal bias cannot be
in the other parts of the machine
learning pipeline they can serve to
exaggerate or mitigate that bias in the
data set but they themselves can only be
statistically biased and not societally
biased but ya'know can make the terrible
mistake of pinpointing the exact root
cause of this problem and not addressing
the I guess wider ranging problems in
the field as some people perceive it and
he shouldn't have to write he pretty
clearly says this is why it happens we
can solve it by swapping the dataset he
doesn't say anything about anything else
namely he doesn't say that general bias
in the field is not a problem
he doesn't say that this doesn't harm
anyone none of that he simply suggests a
solution
Jonathan Peck says well yes that's the
point ml researchers need to be more
careful selecting their data so that
they don't encode biases like this and
Lacan responds with not so much ml
researchers but ml engineers the
consequences of bias are considerably
more dire in a deployed product than in
an academic paper which is also correct
this paper was about the method showing
that this method works on this dataset
now assume if here makes a interesting
point which I agree with
saying that today ml researchers are
inadvertently powering product of a lot
of non-ai companies who ignorant lis
start with a pre trained birth or ResNet
or Yola from the internet probably
ignoring the license readme and so on
which is a valid point right there are
going to be people that take this and
think oh this is a face up sampler cool
I can use that without noting that this
is simply an example and implementation
on an example data set so you can argue
that there might be some
responsibilities of the researchers
right here that doesn't make yung Lacan
not correct but I still consider this to
be like a fruitful discussion between
individuals right here but now we go on
this person saying train it on the whole
American population with an l2 Lawson
almost everyone will look white or train
it on the whole American population with
an l1 loss and more people might look
black stop pretending that bias does not
also come from algorithmic choices young
the car never says it doesn't right the
car responds now saying the most
efficient way to do it though is to
equalize the frequencies of the
categories of samples during training
this forces the network to pay attention
to all the relevant features for all the
sample categories and training with an
l1 instead of an l2 will not even begin
to solve the problem I would pretty much
argue training with an l1 loss here
would exacerbate the problem because the
l2 loss is much more sensitive to
outliers drawl Sutton says serious
question why do you feel that it's
important to make this point are you
worried that people are going to start
suing cycle gang and Lacan says because
people should be aware of this problem
and know its cause so they can fix it
how terrible yawn how terrible you dare
pinpoint the exact cause of the problem
so that people can fix it the correct
thing to do is to point out that
everything is problematic
so Tim the giver says Jung I suggest you
watch me and Emily's tutorial or a
number of scholars who are expert in
this area
you can't just reduce harms to dataset
bias for once listen to us people from
marginalized communities and what we
tell you if not now during worldwide
protests not sure when so again I feel
the argument here is that you can't
simply point out that it's the data set
bias you must point out the bigger
problems which the on account does not
ever deny he simply says this particular
problem can be solved by switching the
data set Nikola LaRue says Jung was in
my PhD jury I am indebted for him for
everything he taught me but this
constant dismissal of the harms caused
directly or indirectly by the m/l
community is highly problematic where or
when have I dismissed the harm caused by
the m/l community I'm pointing out the
cause of the harm so it can be fixed you
can't fix the harm unless you know what
causes it know the roux says causes of
the biases are numerous only pointing
out data set bias deflects the attention
away from the other more pervasive ones
that make the whole field of bias in ml
many people try to
your attention about these issues but
you kept focus on the data set because
the dataset is the problem right here
he doesn't dismiss any of the other
things he simply says here the data set
is the problem if your problem is that
it doesn't work as well for
non-caucasian people which was never the
intent of this the intent of this was to
showcase the method I mean imagenet is
like 60% dog species and still people
trained on it to showcase their image
recognition techniques no one training
on image net makes a claim that they
have solved computer vision for all the
classes in the world in a fair manner
Tim McGee Bru goes on saying I'm sick of
this framing tired of it many people
have tried to explain many scholars
listen to us you can't just reduce the
harms caused by ML to dataset bias
doesn't do that doesn't do it so someone
asks her is he engaging in any ways with
you it's appalling to see that he
answers to everybody but you yet maybe
there is a conversation going on in
private and I don't want to jeopardize
it note that young Lacoste tweet has 500
retweets 1.9 K likes and comments as far
as you can scroll to what she responds
to with yep but I'm used to white men
refusing to engage with black and brown
women even on issues of bias that mostly
affect us I mean he literally has
ignored a whole body of work by people
from that demographic hence the
statement so not surprised I mean in
absence of the fact that an argument
should be independent of the person
making the argument that is a low blow
heart Meru says I respectfully disagree
with Yun here as long as progress is
benchmarked unbiased data such biases
will also be reflected in the inductive
biases of ML systems advancing ml with
biased benchmarks and asking engineers
to simply retrain models with unbiased
data is not helpful I don't disagree
with you here I don't think my tweet
contradicts your statement which it
doesn't people are reading into this
because he doesn't conform to the
orthodoxy of pointing out that
everything and everything is problematic
and
the pinpoints a particular problem he
must be thinking all the wrong things
Jeff Dean says this is a clear example
here is an illustration that seemingly
minor choices in learning algorithms or
loss can have significant effects so
bias in ML systems is about much more
than just avoid data bias ml researchers
and practitioners must pay attention to
these issues and I think they are and
Lacan doesn't say anything against that
he says as I point out in my comment to
this tweet is much more efficient to
correct this kind of bias
note that Yann Lacan actually
differentiates between the different
kinds of biases by equalizing the
frequencies of categories of samples
during training than be hacking the loss
function correct because if you hack the
loss function you're trying to counter
one kind of bias by another kind of bias
Meredith Whittaker says this is very
racist and even if it recognized
non-white people it would be very racist
this is Coptic it's designed to allow
those with power to surveil and control
those with less power diverse training
sets aren't going to fix it advocating
that we should never build these systems
and that's a discussion to be had but
let me break this to you this isn't
going to help the cops this isn't
actually giving you the face of the
person that was down pixeled this is
simply going to give you the most likely
face associated with that down pixel
picture given the dataset the algorithm
was trained on I don't see this whenever
any machine learning algorithm does
anything with faces at all people
jumping up going like this is cop
technology well in line with all the
broader impact statement advice can't it
also be used to find lost children from
very very bad security camera footage
and if I already mentioned that this
doesn't actually give you back the
person on the down stamp old image it
will give you back the most likely
person given the data set so with that I
want to conclude this section please
stop the witch hunting young account
made a completely fine tweet here and
there's no reason why people should pile
on him this hard he doesn't dismiss any
of the other problems just because he
doesn't mention them and while we all
enjoy a good discussion
where people disagree genuinely is not
helpful to accuse him of things he never
said or meant I mean where does this all
lead the result of this is going to be
that small labs that don't have the
resources to collect their own data sets
or check for all the possible biases in
their models that are reliant on the
data sets that we do have even if they
are biased and flawed we'll just be
disincentivized from publishing their
code or actually doing research at all
so this as every other additional
constraint on research is going to help
the large corporations with lots of
money and maybe that's just my opinion
but we should be able to just talk about
a problem and the solution to it without
always having to make sure that we
rabble down all the different things
that are and might be wrong according to
the Canada and big props to young
lecounte here for holding his own 90% of
people by now would probably be like oh
yes I'm so sorry I did a not thoughtful
comment blah blah blah
props tyrion keep going and with that I
conclude this section let me know what
you think in the comments and I'll see
you next time bye bye
[Music]